hey Luke here at the altar boys YouTube
channel and it's been too long since
I've done a blacksmithing video so we're
gonna Forge ourselves a big old fishing
spear and poke some fish come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wait what happened did you poop on my
raft
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right while I'm working on my Forge
spear I'm also going to make a couple of
fishing Spears for my boys here hey
Tommy
once come over here and pick which one
you want we've got these two bnm fishing
gigs that's a pretty cool looking spear
right there all right I have a one-inch
diameter replacement broom handle here
we're going to use for the spirit is a
rainy cold spring morning and we are
going to make the shaft to this spear
I've got a 7-foot long piece of IPE this
is a South American hardwood that's
about three times harder than Hickory
this stuff is heavy and it is hard it
feels like an iron bar in your hand and
I want a one-inch diameter shaft and we
have about a two and 1/8 to 1/4 inch
piece of wood here so I need to rip it
right down the middle very very
carefully and if I do that I can have
two shafts and I don't know when I'll
ever get my hands on a piece of EPA
again so I want to make sure I have
enough for another spear project
well handheld jigsaw is not the ideal
tool for this but it's what I got and so
the first thing I'm gonna do with the
angle grinder is smooth out the little
school um pused parts then I'm going to
knock the corners off and we're going to
begin the process of turning this into a
long straight smooth dowel
[Music]
this wood is so hard just like steel all
right there we go
pretty straight I'm happy with it
[Music]
all right we're back in the garage and
I'm gonna be sanding this thing I'm
gonna start with some 60 grit sandpaper
then work up to 320 then I'm gonna go to
800 then 1,200 and this thing is gonna
be so awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that is a gorgeous piece of wood right
there we're getting close I got this old
antique ice fishing spear I'm gonna
clean this up and put this on a handle
as well I've got this one and a quarter
inch closet dowel here that we're gonna
use as a shaft and see how that goes
it's a little thicker than I'd like but
we'll see if we can make it work
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
well there you go guys if you're not up
for hand forging your own fishing spear
by one used off of ebay for 10 15 bucks
and then about 30 40 minutes you can
take a closet pull and turn it into a
very good looking spear shaft this will
work really well all right so we're done
with the fish spears let me show you
what we got this right here is the one I
did last year and this is the one I just
finished today
and the only real difference between the
two is the new one has barbs on the
tines and it's a smaller diameter shaft
so overall this is a lighter spear also
it has more tines and it's slightly
wider but it has slightly less space in
between the tides
additionally the tines are parallel as
opposed to slightly spread out and
tapered on this on this one so just some
small improvements I think will make it
a little bit better to use this is the
antique ice fishing spear head and the
closet pull and it looks really nice all
of our Spears I put little holes in the
back so we can attach them to lanyards
we've got these two little Spears here
this is good for like bluegill or
smaller fish and this one can be better
for frogs or other things and both
extremely light so the boys can use them
alright we've built the Spears now we're
gonna go poke some fish
alright guys there she is the floating
fishing cabin we're gonna do a little
modification to get it ready for
spearfishing well there we go got the
cabin off the raft and replaced four
bins and we're gonna put some lights on
this thing there we go got all six
lights installed just need to go charge
up our battery and we're good to go
alright guys we've been forging and
building and preparing and now it's time
to spear fish and I'm bringing the boys
along we're gonna go do that until we're
ready to spear okay there we go
yeah it does look cool alright guys what
kind of fish do you want to get today
and Tommy you want to catch a carp right
you like to eat carp I want to snake it
sit there and see it you see you got the
spotlight see look here in the grass
right here look around look for grass
that's moving see right there how it's
like there's a little cloud of dust
coming up that's because there was the
big fish there and when he saw us he ran
away oh there's one right there Nathan
Nathan yeah it's a small one it's the
perfect one for you right there
see him well you missed
yeah the riffles right there see oh I
think he actually came close that dive
Nate why here date right look at my
light look at my light look at my light
look I know what light right here oh
yeah there you see him oh look at that
right there right there Dave see look at
big shanty
you see if you hit the boat you scared
him so bad you swam right into the boat
and over there see their carpet see a
carpet
see the carpet you want to eat him then
you go for it Tom and he is he's big
I I think you nicked him yeah but he got
away he's God you got so close to that
carp you probably came the closest about
all many of us our batteries are gonna
die soon and then they'll probably go
home detect you well you have a spear I
think it's a fair fight oh the grass is
twitching right there oh look right
there see that see that see that that's
wholesale hold still hold still
where'd he go well we just saw a big old
snakehead first catch of the day throw
him back get the whole bag yeah he just
jumped on the boat right did you guys
have a good time would you like to do
this again sometime
seven weeks okay well guys it's another
day I'm gonna have another go at this
spearfishing
unfortunately that that raft just didn't
work out
so I'm gonna go back using the paddle
board like I did last year I just think
it's a lot more effective so we've just
got a few more seconds here before the
Sun completely sets and we're gonna get
started all right so I've got my spear
here with me and I've gone ahead a zip
tied kayak paddled to one side of it and
I got myself a bungee cord leash on the
end of it so if I chuck it I won't lose
it
well I haven't been on this thing in a
year
my paddleboard is rated for 230 pounds
I'm a healthy 250 and you just listen to
it groan something big is running around
in here I could see a lot of dust
kicking up
there's fish running well there's right
there that's a bass I'll be there right
down there yeah that is a nice healthy
bass right there
pear a big carp right there yeah so many
of them right there
right there man I love snakehead though
I really want to snake it oh there's
another carp right there yeah they're
just everywhere in here right there
right there that's a big one huh hold on
that's a snake oh there was two of them
damn that was a pretty easy shot too and
I miss it that was two big snake heads
they're only in like two feet of water
foot and a half of water one of them was
sitting under a stick that wasn't as big
as he was the other one was just out in
the open next to him and they were just
sitting on the bottom perfectly still
Oh pelvis is sneakin I scared him but I
didn't come close to hitting them and I
was a big snake big ones in here every
one of these has been over 6 pounds and
shattered all over me today he got away
Barb's aren't doing much there's the
best and I think man I'm seeing lots of
bedding baths today
she had jumped out I want to get away
from me yeah Chad jumped on the water
under the boat ramp to get away from me
well I saw a bunch of snake heads got to
throw the spear around a bit but no dice
it's midnight my feet are killing me so
I'm gonna call it for today and we're
gonna try again tomorrow alright it's
day number three and we're gonna see if
we can't catch ourselves a snake head
here waters the touch higher and a touch
of murk here today last time I was here
I can see all of this all the bottom now
I can barely see anything only that big
bass right there
yeah nice way
oh there's snake it right there that's a
it must have thrown right over his back
that was a buffalo wasn't it there he is
there he is yes all right I just speared
that big Buffalo he got away
that was a big fish all right guys it's
day four and we're gonna get a snake
head let's do this this is my day that
beast right there
[Music]
got you I got you oh oh I've been
looking for you for a while sir I took
my time got clothes I took a breath got
him
awesome yeah I do not want to lose this
guy he is speared really good but he
might pop off so I'm gonna go and paddle
back to shore and then deal with this
guy that ought to do it now now I think
it's safe to transport the prisoner
yeah that's a nice one a little smaller
than the one I got last year okay now
that I've caught a fish let me tell you
what I think of this new fishing spear
design I really like that it's lighter
but the barbs did diddly-squat
the few fish that I stuck they popped
off just as easily with the smooth tines
a little bit easier I think because the
tines are shorter there's the other
spear had longer or tines and that made
it harder for the fish to thrash and pop
off when you had them properly skewered
so I just don't think that the barbs
make a big deal I think whether you lose
fish or not is more about your technique
when you spear the fish you've got to
keep them pinned on the bottom and then
reach down and grab him rather than
picking up the spear and hoping he
doesn't pop off I think that's probably
the better way to do things
man I just enjoy doing this just
pursuing these fish with a spear from a
paddleboard at night it's just a kick in
the pants but now I am going to fillet
this thing and cook them up and show you
guys an awesome snakehead recipe a lot
of people confuse these with native
boeuf in the real surefire way to tell
the difference is this anal fin right
here
snakeheads have this super long anal fan
this one's all chewed up bow fin don't
they have just a teeny tiny little anal
fin so if you get a long skinny fish
like this you're not sure what it is
look at the anal fin flaying these fish
is super easy just make an incision
behind the pectoral fin in the Gill
plate go all the way the back follow
right here along the spine then open it
up and go down to the tops of the ribs
and then just trace along the ribs the
ribcage only really pokes out about this
distance here behind the pectoral fin so
once you get past that just kind of lay
your your knife blade flat and just go
down the fillet
you want to take the skin off on these
fillets
but these snakeheads have really tough
skin so it's it's pretty easy to do
because it's hard to cut through the
skin from here to here there's this
little line of bones right there easy to
get rid of there you can see snake it
meat is a very nice firm white meat last
thing I want to do is see what this fish
was eating that's all it was in his
stomach and it's just a big pile of
bones and scales now normally I like to
do different recipes each time I do
these videos but I have a snakehead
recipe that is so stinking good I just
can't do anything but it I just love it
too much I'm gonna make coconut crusted
mango drizzled snakehead I want to make
it a little different than I've done it
in the past just because the ingredients
I have here in the house but let me show
you how to do it now normally I like to
use the Naked brand mango puree because
it's so thick and it reduces really well
but I don't have any of that I don't
want to run to the store so I'm gonna
use this mango orange juice what you're
gonna do is we're just going to boil it
until all the water goes out until it
becomes so thick that it just slides off
a spoon it'll take probably about an
hour all right because I'm using orange
juice and not straight mango juice it's
a little bit tart when you boil it down
so I'm just gonna put just a pinch of
brown sugar in there and I need to
thicken it up a little bit cuz just
reducing it alone doesn't quite cut it
so I am going to take
a little cornstarch
look at that said thickens right up all
this all right so I've got flour egg and
one part panco with one part sweet and
coconut shavings and we're just gonna go
ahead and roll the fish and this alright
now we're gonna put the fish in the oven
at 400 degrees for about 10 minutes
well very firm flaky meat look at that
mmm you like that if you guys liked this
video make sure to check out the first
snakehead spear forging catching cooking
video I did it's on my other channel the
catfish and carp YouTube channel there's
over 500 videos on that channel so if
you haven't checked it out make sure to
go check that out as well I'll put a
link in the description but thanks for
watching guys hope you enjoy this video
and I'll see you next Saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like that and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning
and hit that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching